this is real it's filled with a lot of
Beautiful Moments and beautiful people I
have a loving family an incredible
boyfriend that I love so much beautiful
friends and family people that I miss
it's a privilege to miss people the way
that I do but it's hard and it's lonely
it's very lonely I just know that if
that loneliness can exist so can other
things and I will be okay maybe that's a
weird takeaway
I just can't deal with the chicks crying
on camera I just really I don't have a
lot of sympathy you know you have a role
that women would dream of having and you
said something entitled the people
comment on it and instead of coming
forward and being like walking it back
she just says I'm I'm in my brain 24th
like